how's Gomes - Peter Pan today is a very
special day cuz today we're gonna
fabulous youtubers I'm only gonna pick
youtubers that I met personally I don't
want anyone to take offense I think you
bros know I'm not like that
so dad and Phil is probably what I
thought would be the most requested ever
let's just do a regular good old Face
Swap and go from there that does not
look [ __ ] up at all
damn it looks very good I would say if
very good is very bad then he looks
amazing is just like doing plastic
surgery except making them uglier
they're so similar it's not like it's
much of a difference all right we're
gonna have to get creative here okay I
found a better photo I can definitely
work with this let's add a couple of
chins bring me yeah yeah yeah my god
what have I done what what happened who
created this monster I'm so sorry
okay let's do one with Phil - so he
doesn't feel so he doesn't feel excluded
haha this picture would've been perfect
where's the source I found the source I
don't know what to do with this I don't
I don't know what I'm doing but I'm
sorry ah nice
alright I like where this is going
artwork complete I'm sorry Phil I'm
sorry Dan but you look fab wait wait
wait wait I forgot something
this became way more elaborate than I
ever imagined let's see what your Bruce
think woke up like this
dan looks like a scared ass - none other
than Toby Turner whoops
uh that's there for research which photo
is easier to explain this or this let's
do a quick one with Toby I spent way too
much time on Dan and Phil these freaked
me out every time and this something
about them
I don't know Toby was part of The Hobbit
Wow yeah that looks good let's add a
little hat on Toby sir Toby joins the
fabulous crew
you sell families I like it I like it a
lot
I don't know why see what you must think
I have seen the gates of hell come on
what it's beautiful I think it looks 10
times better I think so too
please stop step down I better stop oh
[ __ ] my vagina is ready
don't don't tweets no he looks like the
Pringles dude
hahaha alright we have time for one more
tonight Prez let's find a good one all
right
a lot of you breath suggested markiplier
I found this picture which we could
probably easily make some Ganim so just
want to point out I have no [ __ ] idea
what I'm doing
as always but I think this is very hot
and it's actually turning me on quite a
lot what oh god that's even worse what
the [ __ ] he looked like a Protoss kind
of I don't have any evidence for it
but I think this is what you see when
you die okay you know what I'm done this
is this is just too [ __ ] weird what
happened oh there we go
boys who eat their selves girls with
terrible grammar what's worse
I'll never forget this image so that was
this episode of fabulous a which
youtuber do you want to see fabulous
next let me know if you this was a good
idea or not and that's all for me for
now as always thank you for watching
I'll see you in the next one it comes to
brofist
[Music]